hey we see the oh sorry I didn't see you
there
I'm Walter Brennan Zack and this is top
five today and next week we're covering
the actor that you've probably been
waiting for the most since we started
the show no not him yet I'm talking
about Nicolas Cage one note before we
get started if you're looking for last
week's top 5 it's over unbid me because
of copyright issues here so make sure
you go and check out the top 5 best
Undertaker matches now this man is one
magnificent bastard Nicolas Cage has
ascended beyond that of a mere actor or
celebrity Nicolas Cage is on a level all
his own Nicolas Cage is a state of mind
man while it's easy to point out his
boisterous loud baffling and straight-up
strange performances let's not forget
that mr. Cage is one hell of a thespian
he's not an Oscar winner for nothing
Kay just some extraordinary roles to his
name and before we delve into the
bizarre jungle of cages worse next week
today we're counting down is top 5 best
performances efg hijk LMNOP number 5
high McDonagh in raising arizona this
Coen Brothers production is an early
example of cages quirky range it
contains the signature style of a Coen
Brothers comedy while really letting its
star spread its wings in a few scenes
ex-con high and ex-cop Edie often see
each other while high as being booked at
the police station eventually they fall
in love and marry soon however the
newlyweds find out they can't have
children inconsolable they become
desperate enough to steal a baby from a
family who just had quints genuinely
caring for and raising the child is
their intent but a reward is put out and
several people come for the baby
including highs recently escaped prison
friends and a dangerous bounty on it
Holly Hunter is in this movie you know
what that means
today if a day for Trax cages his weird
self in this 1987 effort but his
character is given some really nice
depth as we hear his narration he's a
bit rough around the edges but can be
very warm and sincere there's no
shortage of physical comedy in this
Elmas cage shows off how funny he can be
in that regard he also works very well
off his co-star it's an early role that
helped establish his eccentricities
while showing off what he could do with
this type of unusual character with
moonstruck hitting theaters that same
year the young cage was just getting
started number four
David spritz in the weatherman I really
enjoyed this movie it's a side of cage
we've seen before but he's presented in
a way that made his performance feel
fresh a Chicago weather man named David
spritz has a successful career but a
very unhappy personal life he's divorced
from his wife his kids barely speak to
him his father is sick and people
constantly throw food at him when a
national weatherman job opens up in New
York
David is seriously considered for the
position now he has to decide if
preparing his family life is more
important than furthering his career or
if they go hand-in-hand despo FIFA chess
by cocaine build in American accent and
it sounds really weird Jackson lives
with your wife and kids what is possible
are you aware of that what that her
colleagues called her cameltoe living
close to Chicago I always love seeing it
represented on screen and especially in
the wintertime
this movie has some great cinematography
which sets a sort of melancholy mood
cages character is a guy who's very much
at a crossroads in his life he often
reflects on the mistakes he's made while
trying to find the best course of action
for himself and his estranged family
going forward we get to join him on that
journey of self rediscovery while
connecting with his flaws and triumphs
no matter how small and all the
constables I faced and the sorts of
people I could be all of them got
reduced every year to fewer and fewer
until finally they got reduced to one
to Who I am we see David try to
reconnect with his family including his
daughter which is very difficult for the
both of them when we see a little
glimmer of a connection
it feels earned look great look all
grown up okay change let's get some more
nearly sure and then we'll go show pop
pop singers David's relationship with
his father is something I also really
liked here their chemistry is very off
beat sometimes almost too much but the
art these two go through is very
engrossing to watch don't dine it Robert
give me time to get it together give me
a little while let me get the hello
America job I can get it together
[Music]
the movies tone allows for a mix of
funny but simultaneously sad moments
that come up very poignant laughter go
see my kids
you put fucking posture um I go fantasy
Mike is a funny man who see your physics
union I have my fellow ultimately the
weatherman is about accepting one
situation because that's what however
that doesn't mean you have to look at it
in a negative way most of the time we
accomplish a lot more than we think we
do just by pushing forward and living
life cage embodied that inner struggle
in a very relatable way and I think it's
a performance that you should see number
three
Roy Waller in matchstick men so I love
this move I love almost everything about
based on Eric Garcia's novel of the same
name Roy and his partner Frank are con
artists who are very good at what they
do as Roy's prominent OCD starts to
worsen he finds his long-lost daughter
Angela and with his new medication if
symptoms start to subside when Angela
shows interest in entering the family
business Roy struggled with keeping his
daughter innocent his con man crimes or
bonding with her as all of this is
happening a big job involving a
businessman is a large enough scam to
potentially be dangerous before I get
into cages performance I want to say go
watch this movie Ridley Scott directed
it and I could not recommend it more
cages signature acting style can
obviously be peculiar at times here that
all works because this character has OCD
and he can twitch out to his heart's
desire
ever heard of a lie have you ever been
dragged to the sidewalk and beat for you
cast blood while that works on the
surface what really makes this a
top-three performance is his sincerity
in his relationship with his daughter
man this is an incredibly believable
pair Alison Lohman and cages chemistry
leaps off the screen and every stage of
their development as father and daughter
is enthralling it ranges from
heartbreaking to pure joy and back
several times over nice to meet you
nice me definitely that is what what you
did and your nosey Parker go yeah and
don't ever call me again
okay don't matchstick man is a heist
film with real stakes and one of the
strongest heartbeats I've seen in a
movie like this cage is just so good in
it my advice would be not to look up too
much else about it just go into it as
fresh as you can it's probably my
favorite movie on this list number two
Charlie and Donald Kaufman in adaptation
cage was nominated for his performance
here and he played two brothers who are
very different partially based on Susan
Orlean book the orchid thief adaptation
follows screenwriter Charlie Kaufman as
he struggles to adapt said book into a
screenplay Charlie often feels
inadequate and his self-loathing point
of view negatively affects his
day-to-day life with his brother Donald
living with him events begin to show
parallels to Susan Orlean herself as
both writers look to find true passion
in their lives lives it slowly starts
become intertwined the best parts of
this movie feature cage just talking to
himself she I was kidding Tom oh okay
sorry you got me you mind if I use it up
you can't get goofball you can't be an
asshole known asshole
cage is very different here it's been
reported that he ignored all his
instincts and totally trusted director
Spike Jones on how to play both
characters it turned out pretty well for
him as this performance sticks out in a
good way from most of his other work he
successfully makes the viewer feel
extremely uncomfortable in a few scenes
that have us pity him I'm going up to
Santa Barbara this Saturday for an
orchid show and I oh I'm sorry well
in a profound moment we get a great
little monologue from Donald that
teaches Charlie and the audience an
important honest blessings you are what
you love no one looks tired a long time
the movie blurs the line between fiction
and reality my professors used it a lot
in my film education classes to show
examples of writing a unique screenplay
and presenting layered storytelling
while cage didn't win the Academy Award
for these roles it's absolutely one of
his best performances and just missed
out on the top spot this was not an easy
list to construct Nic Cage has a lot of
strong performances so before we get to
number one here are a couple honorable
mentions
and the number one best Nicolas Cage
performance is Ben Sanderson in leaving
Las Vegas Cage won the 1996 Academy
Award for Best Actor in a leading role
for this performance
it's a powerhouse portrayal about a man
who finds a little bit of comfort at its
absolute lowest low adapted from the
novel by John O'Brien leading Las Vegas
these hopeless alcoholic Ben moved from
LA to Las Vegas where he intends to
drink himself to death however once
arriving he begins an unconventional
relationship with a prostitute named
Sarah and together they find acceptance
and comfort in each other but this
doesn't stop Ben's desperate drinking
which eventually begins to threaten the
unique pair's connection this is quite
possibly the most uncomfortable movie
I've had to watch for the show cage
plays a man who has decided to end his
life in a slow sad way he's scarily
believable as his character is shown
going from bad to worse even if
something positive comes into his life
you can never never
asked me to stop drinking to understand
this downward spiral is raw and feels
very authentic what makes things even
more disheartening is that hope is
within reach but he doesn't latch on to
it in a way that improves his situation
I'll tell you right now I work with you
but be that as it may I am NOT here to
force my twisted soul into your life
while both he and his new companion
Sarah are self-destructive Ben is
clearly worse off as the scenes with her
trying to take care of him just come off
as pathetic it's a downer of a movie but
it features Kage and his most real and
it's no wonder this was his most lauded
performance check it out if you could
handle a very dark rounded story there
you had it Nic Cage is legitimately
awesome he's a very very talented guy
and can still pull out a great
performance when he wants to these were
his best in my opinion but somehow I
think I'm going to have a tougher time
next week I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite Nicolas Cage
movie and/or performance what do you
want me to cover next in the show leave
a comment and let me know for more
content subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter and
follow me on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what I may cover in the
future come back next week when we jump
back into the cage to find his worst
performances QRS TUV wxy
[Music]
hasta luego co-writer and I played my
brothers whatever I was really proud of
myself